okay so Rick and Morty is back and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down all the Easter eggs hidden
details references and things you missed
in season 6 episode 6. the entry
features dinosaurs returning to Earth
and relieving us of our quote-unquote
duties the episode is titled jurisic
Mort and no prices for guessing this is
a play on Jurassic Park their franchise
was obviously about bringing dinosaurs
back too and after their escape in
Fallen Kingdom they start to make the
Earth their home however these aliens
come back and giant ships that surround
the planet though the colors are off the
shape of them highly resembles the ones
from the movie arrival that too is about
visitors from space coming to show us a
new way to live and Dinos kill us with
kindness throughout the entire episode
now the episode opens with Rick sitting
on the couch drinking you might have
noticed last season that he never really
had the drool around his mouth and that
he'd also stop burping this is because
Justin Rylan had to drink busy drinks in
order to do it and he got to the point
where he just didn't want to put his
body through that anymore season 5 had
him drink King barely any alcohol and
the Jewel disappeared but here it's back
this shows up more at the end of the
episode when Rick hosts the Oscars and
he smashes up the mic stand which we
learn is actually staged anyway on TV we
get a split second shot where we see an
advert for ihole serial this was a
fictional serial that appeared on
interdimensional cable 2 which is the
eighth episode of season two we discover
the rift in space still and this of
course closed out season 5 whilst also
opening up this one we're told not gone
yet you remember that don't you it's
probably important and this pays off at
the end of the episode with the dinos
fixing it turns out Rick could have
actually fixed portal travel the entire
time but he was just being stubborn lazy
and his usual Dow herself however this
pushes him to finally mend the
technology so that it no longer murders
those who travel through it episode one
of the Season opened with a clear
reference to Avengers end game and I was
wondering if this Arc was also meant to
be playing on Tony Stark solving time
travel that might be reaching however
Marvel does get mentioned at several
points in the episode president Curtis
brings up endgame and there's also talk
about rounding up Ant-Man either way
Rick goes to shoot a portal and the
Cthulhu monster from the title sequence
immediately pops up nice to actually see
it in an episode and it's likely still
after them because they stole its baby
in the Montage now from here we could to
Harry hips in high school or hhhs for
short Morty entering the classroom sends
everyone into a panic and they take a
similar position to how they would in an
active shooter situation golden fold
asks if he's been the facultate again
and this is a reference to the 1998
sci-fi movie in which aliens took over
teachers at a school the ships fly in
and they pass the Hollywood Sign Taj
Mahal Eiffel Tower New York City London
and lastly we go to Egypt in the
background we can see the Sphinx and I
kind of feel like the depiction of this
is similar how it's presented in Wonder
Woman 1984. they destroyed guns and are
shocked a bit to learn monkeys went bald
anyway at this point we jammed to the
title sequence but for this part of the
video I'm I'm going to ask you to do all
that usual YouTuber crap which involves
a like a comment a subscribe if you
please might fix the world and it
massively helps us out but out of the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the rest of the video
[Music]
now we go to the UN and learn their
origin story some traveled into space to
help out other worlds they're a bit
shocked to learn the rest of their kind
has been wiped out and replaced the
president is once more played by Keith
David and I was wondering if he was
returning for the series as we did have
a change up in the Sim earlier in the
season they bring up a list of some of
the things that Humanity has done and
this includes gunpowder anime body
pillows a reference to Ronald Reagan and
Donald Trump in Celebrity presidents
Jazzercise gluteal implants Marvel
comment section which leave a comment
domestic terrorism Crocs Amazon Prime
fluff another sandwiches capitalism
space tourism Dodge Coin and also social
media they want us to leave most of that
behind and go back to making Marvel
movies because we love it now at this
point we get a montage of several
newspaper headlines similar to something
that you'd see in an old movie the main
one that Springs to mind for me is
Spider-Man and Batman did something
similar to it conveys a lot of
information and over the top of this so
we can hear someone singing several
dinosaur names this includes
kajirasaurus which was of course a name
that was used as an inspiration for
Godzilla the headlines start off by
saying dinos do it all and we can see
the president meeting with a Triceratops
Dino's help crops to grow make food and
clothes free and also Supply free
alcohol at the Barb or none all jobs are
eliminated and every fridge is filled
with a stock exchange being wiped out
there's also no war or news even needed
because everything is cool however this
has robbed Humanity of the very thing
that makes them them I think this is the
Surgeon General now stuck building bird
houses and Tumbleweed while a tumbleweed
display blows through the Oval Office
summer doesn't get any views on Tick
Tock for reasons we can't say on YouTube
and we see that the Raptors even do
menial things like making sure the
recycling goes in the right bin we also
see Beth playing a play on operation but
instead of a human it's a horse because
she's a horse doctor everyone has
basically become Jerry because they no
longer longer have a purpose they don't
receive any appreciation for what they
do and they simply exist instead of
living Rick is the only one who doesn't
care because he was doing what he wanted
to do anyway there have been several
thought experiments in the past about
what one would do if they could create a
perfect life in a simulation and the
results on this have always came out the
same way the majority have stated that
they'd rather have challenges put in
place to overcome rather than having
everything go their way we actually saw
Jerry stuck inside a simulation like
this earlier in the season and he was
trying to win his very first sales pitch
this show that even people like Jerry
crave something to strive for but now
that's been robbed they've all become
him now they do go to Jerry for advice
and we see him on his computer with some
pretty funny files on it firstly there's
a PDF for the ebook on the Kama Sutra
for middle-aged men next there's
forgotten stuff forgotten stuff too
delete this which is still there Titanic
locations and beekeepers Delight cause
Jerry's a basic [ __ ] he's also gonna
file for and is falling over which were
basically videos that were popular on
YouTube when the platform was first
starting out so sound a bit old there
kids and also a snake wearing a mini
skirt as well as an ugly dog image he
has a copy of his manuscript with
several final copies of it which is a
nice touch because everyone is an idiot
and they always called stuff that
including me when I sent through 50
changes to our editors now we get a
split second shot of what his book says
and though I'm not going to read it all
to you it's basically Jerry introducing
how this is his book's introduction
whilst also talking about his family he
mentions that in a way he's a
grandfather and this is possibly
referencing Naruto being the child of
both summer and Morty the title of the
manuscript is called never trying never
fails and though he says he has this
attitude he clearly failed to make a
good book however it does get published
later on by the dinosaurs but Jerry
never gets the credit for it since they
assume the person behind it would be
above that after getting a message from
the president Ian Rick me at the Barbeau
queue for ribs the only owner is a blind
man that spouts off words of wisdom and
we discover that he's actually an AI
because Rick is West wielding him he
breaks down after eating the food and
this scene is also referenced to House
of Cards with Freddie and the president
who we don't talk about here now Curtis
begs Rick to get rid of the dinos so we
can go back to fixing the problems we
cause and in exchange for this Rick
wants to host the Oscars we see this
happen at the end of the episode and in
the crowd we catch the rock Johnny Depp
Jason Momoa Morgan Freeman and who I
believe is Ted Danson there's also Adam
Driver and Ricketts Tom Hanks to shout
out his catchphrase Wilson from the
movie Castaway there's also sasheen
Little Feather who refused to take an
Oscar on behalf of Marlon Brando in his
speech he slammed Hollywood's depiction
of Native Americans and she sadly passed
away earlier this month on the 2nd of
October there are a couple of extra
people in here that have forgotten the
name so so let me know below if you know
him because I don't I don't recognize
him now I think that might be Olivia
Wilde next to the Rock but moving on the
dinos make a shrine of their fallen
ancestors and though Rick says he can
help it turns out they've already done
everything that he wants to they've even
perfected his portal gun and upgraded it
so the traveler can now see where
they're going Morty says the line clever
girl which is a reference to this from
Jurassic Park
[Music]
Rick also talks about being called Laura
Dern because he's about to go elbow deep
in some dino doodoo this too is another
Jurassic Park in which Dunn's character
Ellie ended up putting up with more crap
than you do when I stop busting out
terrible punts they offered to close the
rift but Rick wants to leave it because
it's canonical they teleport Rick and
Morty which completely disintegrates
them it seems like they're even more
powerful than Rick is however he
realizes that because they virtue
signaled so hard they have to have made
some mistakes themselves and they travel
to planets that they quote unquote
helped Mori says life ER and this is
obviously a reference to Jeff Goldblum
in Jurassic Park saying life Earth finds
a way it turns out they've gone extinct
on multiple planets because they are
pretty useless one talks about making a
series of increasingly bad movies about
them being brought back to life in a
theme park and you get you get that one
you get it also the creator of Westworld
Michael Crichton create Jurassic Park as
well so that could be why westworld's
brought up earlier now media has all hit
the planets but this species that
survived all assume the giant credits
were just Hangouts for them one assumes
they love skateboarding and it turns out
they actually do when we see this
playing out in the post-credits Stinger
the Triceratops also done to Thug Life
sunglasses and it's a really cool way to
end the episode Rick arrives at a q a
and says that they've destroyed all the
planets they've visited he mentions how
they're also not secretly there to take
over and at this point I realized the
entire thing could also be a reference
to V in case you don't know this was a
series in which a group of apparent
humanoids came to Earth in order to help
us out but it was revealed that they
were actually lizards that wanted to
take over turns out the Medias
themselves are also sentient life that
are natural enemies of the dinos and
they travel out to destroy the worlds
that they apparently fix got lots of
Majora's masks vibes from the incoming
asteroid and realizing they'd end up
destroying the worlds the dinos are
crushed kids even turn against them so
much that they prefer trains now and we
cut to Anderson Cooper writing them for
being pacifists to the point they won't
destroy the Rock we also see Joe Rogan
and on his desk can catch a CBD can as
well as his shirt which says DMT Rex we
then go to The Wendy Williams Show and
they agree to let us go back to
destroying the world ourselves and we
once more get a montage this includes
mentions of Chernobyl Exxon spilling oil
asbestos in Montana and type 2 diabetes
back in Egypt we see someone holding a
sign with Bye Felicia which is a
reference to Friday and I love how we
also see the guy from the first Montage
stapling his tie back together crime is
up and happiness is down but that's just
the way we like it Kurt back to the
barbecue and the president mentions
Molly earlier in the episode Rick said
that he only ever contacts him for
either help or Molly and this time it
was clearly the latter after the Oscars
Rick admits the entire thing is scripted
and we see a return of space Beth turns
out the dinos are just waiting in space
for the media to hit but Rick saves them
by sacrificing himself well we're going
to sacrifice himself he has dino proofed
his Tech and then now playing virtue
signal chicken what about they say Rick
and themselves but they want up him by
fixing the rift we see the Citadel
destroyed in space beside it and Rick is
good they can't milk it into a
three-episode Arc back home we see that
forest fires are a thing again and
summer has a new follower who will trade
crypto coins for photos of bare toes in
the end Rick fix his portal trouble and
he takes Morty to boob world this was
mentioned at the start of rickel star
rectacular but they never ended up going
however they're off and it's Rick and
Morty for 100 Years baby wrecker body
anyway that ends the episode and upload
the series so far been such a good run
and uh yeah I'm sure you can tell I had
a lot of fun with this one too let us
know your thoughts on it below and if we
missed any Easter eggs then drop them in
the comments we are in competition right
now giving away three copies of dollar
and thunder on the 15th of October and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
want something else to watch make sure
you check out our Brighton of House of
the Dragon which will be linked on
screen right now the latest episode is
out we go over everything in it top to
bottom so definitely head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor let's see in the next one take care
peace